steve you met elvis like backstage
somewhere and and and he i thought he
said the weirdest thing to you about
your comedy like what what well he was
he was absolutely dead on
he really was
i was opening for remember it's 1971.
i was uh backstage i just opened for
anne margaret i knew elvis was coming
that night to see anne margaret cause
they were friends and he was he was
opening the next night or something
and
so i'm waiting backstage and i leave my
door room open so i can see elvis
and by the way my act was you know magic
and i don't think i played the banjo in
that but jokes and weird stuff
and
so here i come i see this vision first i
see a beautiful woman walking
toward me and that's priscilla
all right right i didn't realize that
and then
priscilla
sort of moves away and there's elvis all
in white and this is he looked great and
he had the huge buckle and he looked at
me and he said son
you have an oblique sense of humor
oblique and which was kind of accurate
and then he came in you tell by the
story
he came in and we start talking i think
what do i talk to elvis about
and he said
then he said uh want to see my guns
and i said
yeah
and he had three guns on him and he was
very safety conscious he had he brought
out a derringer and he he held it up he
and he dropped the bullets in his hand
before he gave me the gun so i could
examine you know it's all pearl handled
and engraved and he pulled out another
gun and he dropped the bullet
and now i'm eventually
i'm holding
uh three guns
and elvis is holding 18 bullets
oh my god
i mean that sounds like it could have
been
oh i mean i got a very big compliment
because elvis has a guy who his only job
is to get him out of conversation
so
the guy comes up to elvis and says elvis
we have to go
and elvis looked at him and said
it's okay
oh and then we kept we kept talking so i
felt kind of blessed